Mitch McConnell has been the obstruct ER
and chief sort of the real hatchet man
for Republicans and he's been doing a
brilliant job of just getting in the way
of stuff we've talked about I mean over
the last couple of years he prevented
Merrick garland from having Supreme
Court confirmation hearings under Barack
Obama so Donald Trump got himself an
extra Supreme Court pick thanks to Mitch
McConnell he has been preventing
election security bills from being
debated while he takes money from
lobbyists for the two biggest voting
machine companies in the United States
and he was on Fox News and instead of
addressing any of those obstructive acts
which he should address and I would love
to hear him pressed about he said oh if
Puerto Rico and Washington DC becomes
States that would be part of the
socialist agenda of the democratically
controlled House of Representatives
statehood for DC and Puerto Rico would
be in some way socialistic according to
Mitch McConnell take a listen to this
for the first time in my memory I agree
with Nancy Pelosi I am indeed the grim
reaper when it comes to the socialist
agenda that they've been ginning up over
in the house with overwhelming
Democratic support and sending it over
to America things that would turn us
into a country we've never been there on
the way to doing some additional things
in addition to the ones they've already
done at the green New Deal Medicare for
all and by the way you may have
mentioned this on your show but the
unplanned planned to make the district
of columbia state that given to no
Democratic senators Puerto Rico state we
give them two more New Democratic
senators and the former Supreme Court
Clerk yourself you've surely noticed
that they plan to expand the Supreme
Court so this is a full-bore socialism
on the march in the house and yeah as
long as I'm the majority leader the
Senate none of that stuff is going
anywhere
none of that stuff he says is going
anywhere now understand the complete and
total misdirection that is going on here
Mitch McConnell is sort of good at this
but of course he's helped along by Fox
News by Fox News letting him do it Mitch
McConnell obstructed bills meant to
release an unredacted version of the
Moeller report multiple bills in fact he
wouldn't give him the time of day just
dead on arrival to the Senate Mitch
McConnell continues to obstruct every
election security bill meant to protect
the 2020 election and future elections
from future interference he's doing that
now and his campaign is getting money
from lobbyists for the two biggest
voting machine manufacturers in the
United States and yet he goes on Fox
News and says I control the discussion
in the Senate and no none of this
socialist stuff is going anywhere under
my watch what about election security
that you keep obstructing and then of
course we have to at least briefly
address that DC and Puerto Rico becoming
States isn't socialist socialism of
course defined as a range of economic
and social systems characterized by
social ownership of the means of
production and workers self-management
as well as the political theories and
movements associated with them and as
you can see by looking at the definition
of socialism that territories and
federal districts becoming States is not
socialism I'm not a socialist but when
the right starts calling things
socialism my ears perk up because
there's a very good chance that those
are pretty damn good ideas if they are
being assailed as socialism by
uninformed Republicans Steve King you
might remember horrible racist
xenophobic Republican Congressmen once
said that gay marriage is socialism two
men being able to get married is like
the workers controlling the means of
production what what are you talking
about gay marriage is social ownership
of the means of production this is their
move if they want to oppose something
they call it socialist even if it's not
and in fact DC and Puerto Rico having a
say in government matters that affect
them is not socialism its representative
democracy which I thought was the system
that we had and it's really important to
note that not all Republicans are even
united on this DC statehood thing there
are Republicans that are supportive of
DC statehood there are probably more
Republicans
supportive of Puerto Rican statehood
rather than DC statehood but this is the
post-modernism that they claim to oppose
they accuse us of having no fixed
meanings for language and concepts and
words everything is malleable nothing
has any meaning it can all be whatever
we want it to be and then they say Oh
statehood for territories and federal
districts that's socialism which implies
words have no meaning nothing means
anything anything can be socialism if
Republicans determine that it's bad this
guy must be removed as important I would
say as the removal of Donald Trump from
the White House when you think about
just the next several decades and the
impact on the justice system and the
courts and so much else we've got to
remove Mitch McConnell it's it's if it's
not as important as removing Trump it's
very very close